Good morning John!
Last week I said some really mean things about
books, and books actually saw the video and
left a really nasty comment.
As an apology, let's talk about the best entertainment
investments you can make.
There are lots of different kinds and levels
of quality of entertainments, and also different
amounts of money you can spend being entertained.
Worst investments are usually live events.
Of course hopefully that means that the quality
of the entertainment is higher.
The Super Bowl, for example, this year a very
bad game, not interesting.
People pay upwards of two thousand dollars
to get a ticket to the Super Bowl for less
than four hours of entertainment!
That's, that's more than five hundred dollars
per hour of entertainment.
That's about as bad as you can get.
Vidcon- also a live event but it goes for
a long time.
It's two days, and like, all the way around
almost, it's like 10 a.m. to 2 a.m.
If you're spending all of that time being
entertained, and I hope you are, and you pay
the current 150 dollar per ticket price then
it's five dollars per hour of entertainment.
That's pretty good!
It's the same as if you pay ten dollars for
a two-hour movie, as long as you don't buy
the tremendously overpriced snack foods.
Also as long as you're not seeing a 3D movie.
Or in the special theater, or it's a special
edition movie, or you live in a place where
it's more than $10.
Video games are one of the most popular forms
of entertainment these days, usually debuting
about $60 and taking about 40 hours to beat.
Not bad at all!
Comics, though I love them and they're beautiful
little pieces of art, and sometimes they do
hold on to their value- bad investment.
Takes like 20 minutes to read and is 3 bucks,
so that's bad.
Board games and card games are generally a
fantastic investment, so long as you play
them.
So once you accept the cost, every time you
play it you are getting a better value.
Now let's bring it on back to my friend books.
The Fault in Our Stars is currently on sale
at Amazon for seven dollars.
This book, it took me about 20 hours to finish.
I'm admittedly a slow reader so let's shave
some time off of that.
46 cents per hour!
This- now we're talking!
At the same time though all of our other entertainments
are much more expensive than this, so really
it's probably OK to pay full price for that
book.
I'm only paying like 67 cents more per hour!
Really, to me, that's the amount of money
I am paying to the local bookstore when I
buy it there rather than on Amazon.
67 cents per hour of enjoyment that I am trading
in exchange for a place where I can go and
look at books!
Nice people who will help me find things!
shelves and shelves of opportunity!
Of course, we haven't even mentioned America's
main source of
entertainment, that being television.
Average cost of cable television package is
a hundred and twenty eight dollars per month.
Now that's a lot of money, but since the average
American spends -and I cannot believe this
is true- 34 hours per week watching television,
it's actually a really good deal!
However, no one's pretending that the amount
of time you' spend watching TV is comparable
to the amount of time you spend enjoying Vidcon.
Hopefully, 20 hours of Vidcon is more than
10 times more entertaining than 20 hours of
television.
And yeah, I think 20 hours of reading a book
is probably more enriching than 20 hours of
playing Grand Theft Auto.
It doesn't seem like there's a huge amount
of correlation between the amount of dollars
delivered and the amount of value delivered,
which is why I guess it makes sense that a
lot of the best things in life are free.
(singing Money (That's What I Want) by The
Beatles)
But you can keep 'em for the birds and bees
I want money
That's what I want
(speaking)
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.